soon as people kind of found out we were
doing we're doing this everyone was like
headlines for days so much Nathan and
Ariana that is so kind of you
that's Nathan Sykes formerly of the
wanted now he's so low and for his new
single over and over again he enlisted
his ex-girlfriend Ariana Grande
any apprehension about possibly you know
collaborating reconnecting with someone
you were once linked to no you know what
I think it's only as awkward as everyone
else makes it to the end today that was
what happened happened it feels like
three hundred years ago so it's not
weird me too I think the most important
thing for me was that she's an
incredible vocalist and I really think
she brings something greats to song I
think it shows real majority that we can
both kind of just do this and not really
let it a love song a romantic video is
art imitating life Nathan says not quite
I'm definitely not in a relationship I'm
just happy I'm not kind of desperately
looking for relationship I think he's
one of them things if it happens to
happens and and if it doesn't then I've
been I'm very happy being single you're
married to the music you could say them
must three qualities you want a
significant other no manners that's good
etiquette just a generally a nice person
okay and a good sense of humor well
that's important yeah I mean they've got
to appreciate my sense of you're collec
unique yeah we'll stay brand new cuz I
love you over and over again